this is my second time at a convention I
was here last year it was a lot of fun a
lot of craziness a lot of shenanigans I
figured out how to do it this year so
you know you test the water a jokes and
things you find out what works what's
funny you use them you take them on you
find out what jokes don't work and then
when you finds it up someone else it's
got a really funny joke you steal it say
it first on the next one
and then literally you're the funniest
thing around and they look I know just
like going oh really dude you're gonna
steal my gags I'm like dude you snooze
you lose just saying that's and that's
that that's how you work on so this is
my tester it's just my second so I mean
you're getting me like you know fresh
any way you want me you're warming me up
you know so I'm if you come back this
afternoon I will be killing the game
I'll have Bob's gags I love Murray's
gags Isaiah's jokes
not going to happen I'm the prankster so
yeah I'm the one that gets everyone in
trouble I'm the one that lied
what was her well done lately ah what by
done I'm a prank call people all the
time I called a friend up and said I was
uh I'd broken down it was like 2:00 in
the morning
and I was like I'm just at 7-eleven uh
buh buh buh buh buh can you come grab me
and he was like really I was like I yeah
yeah please and he drove down to
7-eleven he said where I was I'm in bed
I'm joking why would you do that you
know me
why would you do that um by pointing
dinner
I've won dinner and yeah exactly it's
all about that bonding that friendship
I mean you can do I mean you've got
questions about you know the show and
everyone else can answer we could just
talk about life how you guys doing yeah
I mean did you not fill up your coffees
before you come should get the vodkas go
and get the bad stuff
but anything
the writers are very busy I'm it's very
much a sci-fi feel this season season
three more so than the previous seasons
it was very real season two you know
it's it wasn't very sci-fi you know this
stuff happens you know you could have a
post-apocalyptic world two factions
fighting each other you know people
different political beliefs this season
we're going to branch out we're going to
keep that to two world scenario that we
have you know where they don't they go
off on a tangent where you've got two
worlds it keeps it fresh for the
audience so Joe hard Murph you're going
to investigate in the AI story and then
you're going to have more investment in
the factions that we've already met so
the grounders and the sky crew what's
going to happen there because things
didn't end very well at the end of the
season so we're gonna invest in
investigate that we're also going to
find out about how the apocalypse
happened we're going to remove Inigo
we're going to go into you know the
origins it's always it's always a trend
that them you know that show is kind of
following at the moment everything
everyone's about the prequel so we're
gonna we're gonna follow suit a little
bit not not completely it's different a
touch on on what happened and why it
happened
and the effects that it has on the
environment today and then it's just
going to be more the same just lots of
deaf lots of a lots of darkness lots of
incredible layers layered storylines you
know the great shot great thing about
our show is is that there's no good guys
or bad guys only perspective so you know
depending on what side of the fence you
fall on you're going to fight for your
people the mountain men last year we're
seen as the bad guys if you're a
mountain man you're just fighting for
your own people you just want to go back
on earth so we're going to investigate
all these kind of new dynamics and new
characters are going to come in this
season going to find out more about the
ground the world and about the world
that we haven't seen you so around the
forest and what's going on we're going
to realize that there's a lot more
civilization then than we know so
there's gonna be a lot of investment in
that and then as far as Lincoln goes you
know he's still got his love Octavia
there now amongst the the sky people and
what problems is that going to bring I
know
you're one of a of hundreds or thousands
of people everyone's kind of got eyes on
you you're almost set an example can can
they live together
well here's to right now that they're
doing it but will that last and will
link can be provoked you know he's he's
different you know he's gonna be amongst
these people who not necessarily they
don't know ground is they all they know
is that the grounders have killed a lot
of their people and here's a grounder in
their own home and they're forced to
live with him so there's gonna be trust
issues and you know Lincoln's going to
face a lot there but he's got Octavia by
his side but they're gonna have their
own problems too you know they were
split up for the whole a second season
so now that together we have real real
relationship problems it's you know
everyone loves a long-distance
relationship you know they'd then love
you to bits soon as you soon as you meet
up and yet you're under each other's
feet feet every day times get tough you
know she's going to realize it you know
Lincoln doesn't put the seat down on the
toilet you know and you know Octavia
leaves her shoes everywhere you know so
we're going to we're going to experience
you know some real relationship stuff
and you know that relationships just
going to grow and just be tested you
know and they're still going to
constantly put you know themselves at
extreme risk and you know for each other
you know
you